merci merci isabelle pour les gens qui
me connaissent pas donc je m'appelle
jean pierre vigier je suis députée de
haute loire
je suis secrétaire national en charge de
l'agriculture à travers ses propos vous
avez compris que nos agriculteurs
souffrent ils sont à bout de souffle
il traverse une crise qui dure qui dure
depuis longtemps une crise
conjoncturelle mais surtout une crise
structurelle avec une chute des prix
très importantes
l'élevage est touché et la production
laitière aussi mes amis je vous poserai
simplement une question qui
accepteraient aujourd'hui de travailler
et de perdre de l'argent
parmi la salle personne eux c'est ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui
chaque heure chaque minute chaque
seconde travail et ils perdent de
l'argent et ça ce n'est plus acceptable
ça a été dit mais je rappelle
aujourd'hui le gouvernement est
totalement absent au niveau agricole
ils les oublient ils les méprisent il
les ignore et je crois que ce n'est pas
acceptable
regardez le ministre de l'agriculture
ils ignorent les agriculteurs et j'irai
même plus loin il est totalement
incompétent et notre rôle à nous est
républicain c'est d'être à votre écoute
nos amis les agriculteurs et de vous
aider et je crois qu'on a plusieurs
points à développer tout d'abord
revaloriser l'image de nos agriculteurs
on doit être fier de nos agriculteurs
ils doivent être fiers de leur métier on
doit leur donner confiance en l'avenir
aujourd'hui ils ne l'ont plus il faut
rappeler les fondamentaux
l'agriculteur travaille la terre pour
nous nourrir pour nourrir la planète
ils entretiennent l'espace et puis on
doit avoir une vision un modèle
économique de notre agriculture qui doit
être compétitive performantes et
innovantes et ça aujourd'hui c'est
totalement oublié un agriculteur c'est
un chef d'entreprise qui créent de
l'emploi
et ça aujourd'hui c'est aussi oublier et
nous les républiques les républicains on
doit être derrière vous pour vous aider
c'est indispensable
on a un projet ambitieux avec des
mesures qu'on va développer dans ce cas
de cette table ronde 1 pour vous
redonner des perspectives d'avenir et
surtout des marges de compétitivité
c'est indispensable l'agriculteur doit
pouvoir vivre du fruit de son travail de
la vente de ces produits est aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas le cas on a ce travail à
faire on a des mesures concrètes précise
que l'on va développer dans le cadre de
cette table ronde et j'appelle à la
tribune donc yannick fialip qui est déjà
là paul auffray qui est déjà là antoine
herth ce qui va nous rejoindre
député du bas rhin l'excellent
rapporteur de la proposition de loi
compétitivité de l'agriculture
juste un mot sur cette proposition de
loi qu'antoine a présenté en commission
des affaires économiques
nos amis députés ont soutenu ont défendu
fortement cette ppl
mais vous savez ce qu'on fait les
socialistes antoine pourra vous dire sur
chaque article sur chaque article
ils ont rajouté nos propositions ils ont
fait de la politique politicienne
voilà comment ils défendent nos
agriculteurs j'appelle stéphane faudra
céréaliers maud fontenoy tout le monde
connaît je veux pas présenter et
angélique delahaye crois qu'on peut les
applaudir
moi je met alors premier premier sujet
je vais interroger et yannick fialip
étoiles aux frais sur une des mesures je
crois importante que l'on doit
développer fortement
c'est la contractualisation autour des
filières
là il y a des marges de manoeuvre à
obtenir et je crois qu'on a une pression
à mettre sur certaines personnes je te
laisse la parole yannick